[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
Knorr I've heard things that Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where two
brothers answer your questions give you
dubious advice and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon who would that AFC Wimbledon
news John how are you doing oh I mean I
don't know that I've ever experienced
anything so overwhelming in my whole
year it's just it's been a heck of a
rollercoaster for the AFC Wimbledon fans
among us in general Hank I'm doing
poorly I I to be honest with you we were
just talking about this before we
started recording the pod but I I am
abandoning optimism
it was my brand for a long time and I I
really believed in it as one always does
in one's brand but I I am now I have
gone from being pretty sure that we are
in the best year of human history to
being pretty sure that we are in the
best year of human history because all
the ones after this are going to be
worse
[Laughter]
John I've always wondered if maybe we're
interested in writing a nonfiction book
because obviously you create a lot of of
true content about the real world and
all your book stuff though is its
fictional I'm really looking forward to
your future your future non-fiction book
abandoning optimism if I actually read a
nonfiction book it's almost definitely
going to be called the Anthropocene
reviewed by the way episode 2 of my new
podcast the Anthropocene reviewed is
available for your listening pleasure
right now you want to know what I
reviewed this time around tank uh no yes
I do I don't know but I'd want to
Haley's Comet no cholera okay cool
I like that Halley's Comet is an
interesting choice in in that you and
cholera and that you are reviewing
things that are definitely natural
phenomena to some extent though Halley's
Comet I think you could make the
argument is so natural as to have been
impacted by humanity not at all one of
the few objects that we regularly just
that has been in no way impacted by
humanity Oh see I don't agree at all
maybe it hasn't been impacted by
humanity in the sense that we didn't
like change its course or anything but
it has been impacted by humanity in the
sense that we think about it
oh yes it all comes down to if if a
comet flies through the sky and no one's
around to see it
does that affect the comet at all
correct which it definitely does that's
the thing about the Anthropocene
reviewed John available on wherever you
get podcasts is that it takes some
pretty hard turns into some pretty heavy
stuff it is not nearly as funny as I
initially intended it to be that's for
sure speaking of funny today's poem was
suggested by listener Maya Thank You
Maya it's called he visits my town once
a year by Amir Khusrau he visits my town
once a year he fills my mouth with
kisses and nectar I spend all my money
on him who girl you man
no a mango mm-hmm a mango Hank he visits
my town once a year and fills my mouth
with kisses and nectar
I think mangos are my favorite fruits
and so I thought that I would read that
poem about what I think is the greatest
fruit in the history of the world also
while we're on the topic I think it's
important Hank that we note something
that several hundred thousand people let
us know about over the last seven days
which is that dates are not figs correct
they are different things and I feel
like we had that conversation on the pod
John apparently not to anyone's
satisfaction so dates are not figs we
apologize for our positive knowledge on
the date fig front will have some more
corrections later in the podcast one of
which is extremely important but in the
meantime Hank let's answer some
questions from our listeners yeah my
apologies to both dates and figs this
first question comes from Abigail who
asks dear Hank and John my aunt is
getting married over spring break and
we're all very excited as we love my
aunt and her fiance there is a problem
though I was not invited to the wedding
we received a formal invitation about a
week ago and it says
it's a date night please find a sitter
and both of my sister and I are widely
considered to be children and are thus
very distressed my sister didn't sign up
for a high school trip in order to go to
this wedding
have I been uninvited how can we talk to
her about this without sounding like we
don't respect her wishes what in the
world does it's a date night mean in
relation to a wedding
best wishes Abigail oh gosh you've got
to have that conversation I feel like
cuz maybe this means like no tiny kids
but you sound like you sound like a
person who's not a tiny kid yeah just
based on their vocabulary and they're
excellent spelling I don't think they're
in like third grade so yeah this is it's
a tough one because this is a date night
might mean like I want to behave in a
way that I might not necessarily feel
comfortable behaving in front of my 14
year old niece which should be the
choice of the person who's getting
married it might mean I cannot afford
one more plate at this wedding which I
have a lot of respect for in general
when I when I do not even get invited to
a wedding that I expected an invite to I
am grateful to the person and it does
not make me think any less of them or
any less of our friendship because I
remember what every plate cost at my
wedding and it was unimaginable amounts
of money for three to four hours of
ostensibly enjoyment so maybe it's just
that Abigail
maybe you should just tell yourself to
your aunt's wedding isn't even gonna be
that fun it's probably gonna be
stressful the band probably isn't gonna
be any good or there's gonna be a DJ who
plays a bunch of songs from generations
that not only were you not a part of but
you should be grateful not to have been
a part of maybe in the end you're gonna
have a fun night with your sister and
apparently a babysitter I mean there's
also the possibility I mean I don't like
you may not know about this Abigail
because you yeah you seems like you're
under 18 but the the day you turn 18 I
shouldn't even be talking about this
there are a number of things that are
shared with you that aren't we we don't
let anybody
to the age of 14 know about oh right
yeah so so we can't I can't tell you any
of those things obviously you can't even
talk about those things in public in any
format because then that would be
discovered because of course children
are able to consume all kinds of media
these days so yeah it may be it may be
that there just need to need to be doing
some of the things that only people over
the age of 18 are allowed to know about
and and these things have they're not
that interesting they have to do with a
couple of peculiar items of clothing and
a couple of things that one does with
one's toes and it originates
you don't have to worry too much about
it but like you're not allowed to know
about it yet right no it could just be
that they're gonna be using the rituals
that are only available to adults and
that we're not allowed to talk to you
about but I don't feel too bad but do
allow your aunt to have the wedding that
she wants to have even if it kind of
bums you out because it's her wedding
and one day you'll have a wedding maybe
and when you do you can not invite your
aunt and then you can send her a letter
and say that's how it felt that's it
yeah because the point of life is to
hold grudges over decades
Abigail that's the real key to adulthood
I'm just kidding don't hold grudges it's
terrible resentment is a bitter pill
that you swallow if you the next
question that is what my silence
indicated you should be doing okay
instead of harping upon regret okay and
grudges holding grudges if I told Hank
I'm over I mean it's a new me it's pet
full-time pessimism me get used to him
the next question comes from Michele who
writes Dear John and Hank sometimes when
I listen to the pod I'm confused by the
way you speak about yourselves as
siblings Hank I like this question
because it reminds me of my all-time
favorite semi-serious conspiracy theory
in which people became convinced that we
were not really siblings and were just
putting it on for the cameras so that we
could have this project called
Brotherhood 2.0 but we weren't really
related in a recent podcast John talked
about a nickname that he wanted in
middle school that didn't
go well and Hank seem to know nothing
about this a second anecdote was about
Hank going to prom without a date and
this sounded like news to John and
indeed it was I have no idea if Hank
went to proms or with whom he went or
even who Hanks friends were really also
in the past one or both of you will say
my mom but when I mentioned a story
about my mom to my own brother I refer
to her as mom really strange Dazz
children is it a coincidence that both
of your surnames are green and in fact
you are not related by blood I mean I do
believe that you're truly brothers but
I've wondered if you realize the way you
speak about your childhood sounds a tad
sketchy huge fan of the pod and look
forward to reading Hanks novel an
absolutely remarkable thing which comes
out September 25th these two words go
well together Michelle my Belle
I mean we've well it's hard to talk
about Michelle because you should tell
the truth John don't make something up
it will continue the conspiracy theory
these brothers become he came from the
same parents we have the same parents
yep all the way around both parents say
lived in the same house growing up for
so there's there's a couple of pieces of
this Michelle first or Michelle as would
be assumed by your Beatles lyric
sign-off one we're old now and we don't
remember anything from childhood yeah I
remember a few things about Hank as a
child like I remember that he was
physically smaller than I was but not by
as much as you would expect for the age
difference I remember that he hoarded
money like in a very weird way yeah very
true very obsessive about his money and
not spending it and so I would often
just take it from him and spend it
because you know that's what money's for
I remember that he had a Walkman and
some tapes
I am really the only reason I remember
he had the Walkman Michelle to be honest
with you is that he sometimes hid his
money inside of that Walkman so I'd like
open
the tape player and I would take the
money out and go buy a Slurpee or
whatever
I remember that John John had a tea had
a computer in his room and that was a
big deal
I remember our house I remember John's
friends and how they used to put on
deodorant and I was like they're so
grown up there putting on Dioner and
then I put on deodorant and then I felt
weirded bad about it like I didn't want
to grow up yet I remember things like
that so there are moments but like in
general you got to remember that you're
gonna forget things so when you know I'd
say I've probably forgotten 90% of the
things about my own life and that
includes about John's life and probably
I forgot more things about John than
about me so yeah there's that part and
then there's that John and I have gotten
really used to talking to people like
talking to an audience rather than
talking to each other which is what we
are doing in part here and so we will
not say mom because we aren't thinking
that way and in fact sometimes I will
say our mom to indicate to people that
who I am talking about but more likely
I'm just gonna say my mom because yeah
I'm not thinking about John as much as I
probably should be but we are we do when
we talk with each other privately we do
talk about mom and dad if we don't we
don't try to claim them for only one of
us I don't say what I'm talking to Hank
I don't say like my dad said probably
hurt Hanks feelings although I think we
all know that he is my dad first
literally he's been your dad for longer
the other thing is that I went to
boarding school when Hank was 11 and so
Hank was a little kid when I left for
boarding school a little kid I was a
pretty big kid physically yeah I mean he
wasn't he wasn't the person he is now
you know like and in some ways when I
would come home for the summer every
year Hank would be a different person
than he had been when I left at the
beginning of the school year so I think
that had a big impact on the way that
our relationship developed and then for
most of our 20s we didn't talk that much
like we liked each other a lot and when
we did
have conversations they were always
really interesting conversations but we
just didn't have like a shared project
that held us together and I think that's
something that we've always needed and
boy did we find it or it plus more many
of them yes I mean a Hank would probably
argue that we talk too often now I
remember when you would come home from
school I'd be like John my big brother
and he's so fun and I liked him so much
and then three days later I'd be like I
cannot believe that he's going to be in
this house all summer yeah yeah well
believe me the feeling was mutual I also
couldn't believe that I was going to be
in that house all summer and I would try
to get kicked out of it you know smoking
in my room etc but our parents were just
too kind and loving
there was like coke stay in the tree
house go just live on the streets of
Merritt Park what I find weird about
that is that we didn't have a tree house
we had a fort not a tree house not not
in high school
buddy I was gone by high school I don't
know when the fort got taken down
I mean hey Hank okay question yeah um I
was recently in Florida and I saw a
gopher tortoise and I was trying to
explain to that kids what a gopher
tortoise was and in the process of
explaining it you immediately realized
that like this is a species that has
absolutely no business being alive on
earth in the 21st century but anyway
they do fine I mean it is a slow-moving
land animal we shouldn't have any of
those anymore but that's not relevant to
the story I have a vivid memory that we
had a pet gopher tortoise inside huh
nope
Oh God really definitely not okay I know
dad would never have let us take a like
a threatened species out of the wild
into our home no way can I finish can I
finish okay okay so at that house in the
front yard there was some kind of like
concrete block rectangle do you remember
that at least I don't remember anything
Foundation for a tiny tiny house yeah
yeah there's no house on top of it and
it was by the fort it was by the fort
exactly now I want you to go one level
deeper in your imagination and remember
when for several months there was a
freaking gopher tortoise living inside
of that enclosure I do not remember God
neither does dad but I'm not gonna say
it's impossible
I don't think that we would have kept it
captive and also I don't think that
there were a lot of gopher tortoises in
Merritt Park you know there's no no it
doesn't make sense except that it
happened it I agree it's like it's like
when you wake up from a dream and you're
like wow that's amazing I could fly for
four hours that seems so unusual this
next question comes from Brea or Bria
who asks where do snakes poop out of
great question great question it just
comes right out of the tip of their tail
is just they like wiggle it around you
know like I like the the rattlesnakes
come except they poop comes out that's
not actually what happens that's wrong
it comes my work yeah yeah I think I do
because I think I've seen snake poop it
kind of comes out from the bottom like
near the tail but not quite at the tail
there's a hole and that hole is the hole
that the poop comes out of correct that
is how it works it's the end of the
digestive system and actually a snakes
have tails which is like that's the
weird part to me so like a snake tail
you could think of it in two ways one
there's a head and then directly
attached to the head is the tail right
and it's just poop but physiologically
there is a place at which snakes used to
have legs and they used to have hip
bones and that and all of the like the
body of the snake which looks just sort
of like a tail is actually body and it
has lungs in it has digestive system in
it it has a heart and all the stuff that
happens in a body and then like where
the hips would happen is a place and
that's where the cloaca is that the poop
comes out of and
and then a tail after that and there's
actually like you can see if you hold up
the snake the right way you can see kind
of where a snake's body turns into its
tail I got an image in my head right now
of the snake but it has semi normal arms
and legs and it walks upright and it's
really freaking me out pretty bad is it
like that like human arms and legs so
it's just like a human with human length
arms and legs but then just a skinny
snake body it's human arms and legs but
snake sized so so it's really just kind
of a miniature human but with scales and
a tail and and it's and the fact that
it's naked is upsetting to me like it's
it's humanoid enough that I'm thinking
to myself like this so shorts on are the
scales like skin colored no this the the
arms and legs are definitely skin
colored but the scales are snake colored
so you've got this out instead of that
okay I just got hands it's got hands
where its arms and legs would be so it
is like runs over on on its fingers that
there's actually a word for that it's
called a skink yeah yeah we already we
already invented an animal like that
what we haven't yet invented is a
humanoid snake like a centaur but for
snakes
great question Hank and one that I had
not thought about carefully if it's a
centaur for snakes then it's got like a
human body that sticks up out of the
snake and then it's just like snake like
it like it's a snake that ends in like a
human torso and I feel like that does
exist I feel like there's something
about that I'm like that dancers in my
head yeah I agree
no I'm picturing that it has a snake
head but it can talk and it's very
erudite so it always it only like uses
multisyllabic words and speaks with a
lot of certainty about everything it's
like a Twitter troll
so the echidna which is not via kid
nough it's
it's also called the echidna is a half
woman half snake monster that lives
inside of a cave and there's a number of
other similar similar human snake
crosses hey I'm sorry we have to get to
another question from various
mythologies we have an emergency at one
from Japan that that I would not want to
be friends with we have an emergency
question it just came in three weeks ago
but I've only just seen it and it's from
Shae lane and she writes hi John and
Hank I just clocked my friend's toilet
do I tell them or just quietly wait
until they realize it memento mori SHhhh
Elaine that's though presumably you're
still in the toilet I mean when this
happens to me I like I have I have
developed a strategy and I know that
it's not for everyone I walk out to out
of the bathroom and as rapidly as I can
I go to the owner of the house and I say
where is your plunger yeah if the
plunger is not there if the plunger is
there I plunge and that's what the
plunger is there for I go out the window
burn the house down no I just go I just
go out the way in town maybe I see them
in six weeks or something and they're
like hey did you leave our party and
I'll be like oh yeah I had a thing I got
a I got a call and my brother had an
emergency and I yeah well man I just
like I can't leave that I can't leave
that to the next person you know oh I
can I can yeah absolutely so I'm I'm
just like take me to your plunger and if
they don't have a plunger then I'm like
I mean like I have I have been in this
situation at like a colleague's house
not even like a friend and and basically
it's like okay no one goes to bathroom
until I fixed this and that's yeah and
it was like a 45 minute long process and
was my sweaty the whole time wow it's
like like like fear sweat you know wow
the water pressure was really bad so I
had to like had to get water from
elsewhere to refill the toilet tank oh
did we need to go to here
no I don't think we needed to go all the
way to there but you chose to or here
now I was just trying to solve this
problem and you had to introduce a
really detailed personal anecdote this
next question comes from Adam who asks
dear Hank and John a couple of months
ago my math teacher was talking about
Olympians getting in trouble for drug
use and he said that the Olympics keeps
samples of all of the contestants urine
for a few years so does that mean that
there's some kind of olympic hall of
urine the hall of urine can I go to
Athens to observe the urine of different
athletes compare colors etc cheers Adam
you've got some weird hobbies Adam so
there is indeed a laboratory in Geneva
Switzerland that egg stores Olympian pee
and I don't think it's open to the
public so like it definitely shouldn't
be
haha B then you have to find a different
one but yeah there are many many P Cups
I imagine that they're just pee cups I'm
surprised that like they can like like
ensure that whatever is chemically going
on is not changing over time though I
assume that the chemistry there's ways
to figure out maybe byproducts or etc
and and also like the idea of that is
that they can in the future test for
things that they're not sure that how to
test for right now so that's pretty
amazing but yeah there's a there's a
halt of urine and and it contains some
of the urine of some of the most
accomplished athletes on the planet if
you walked into the home of someone who
you knew well but you'd never been to
their house before okay maybe you died a
colleague
say or a friend whatever you walk in
their house and it's a nice house
everything's well-appointed it's got
marble countertops and all that stuff
and then along one wall there's a
built-in bookshelf with lots of books
obviously a well-read person and then
along another wall there's just hundreds
of maybe three inch tall bottles of
yellow liquid and uh and you ask the
person
I noticed you have a sizeable collection
of containers of yellow liquid what's
the what's what's what's that and then
they said oh I have a urine sample from
everyone who's ever visited my home
would you think that was cool or would
you think that was weird
what like do you think that would be a
cool collection or do you think that
would be like how would you feel in that
moment is my question in that moment
I would feel like I had apparently
signed up for something that I had not
signed up for that's my main concern my
main concern is not like oh look this
like it's like what an interesting hobby
it's like oh now I have to give this
person my piece oh I don't know yeah I
think you could just say like well for
the record I technically have not
visited yet and then you make a decision
right then I I what made me think about
this and I may have told this story on
the pod before because if you have proof
the hair oh yeah I have okay it's so
profoundly upsetting to me I think about
it all the time I tell that story all
the time now to whatever just like I
can't believe it for those of you who
haven't heard John once went to a
person's house had they had a lock of
their child's hair from every haircut
they had from birth to the age of 18 in
the public front bathroom yeah and in
the bathroom that is reserved especially
for guests as if to say this is what I
want the people who visit my home to
look at while they urinate in a way the
art that goes in your guest bathroom
should be the art that you're most proud
of because it's the art that people are
most likely to take a good long look at
and that is what's so disturbing to me
about it that it was it was every I
can't emphasize this enough it was
hundreds of haircuts okay yeah
so if you're gonna take a piece of every
person who comes into your home what is
the way to do that that isn't the ways
we have so far discussed that might
actually be interesting and kind of cool
okay no I got one don't give me like a
fingernail clipping I got one pee in a
cup
I got what is it on on the way out the
door every person who visits the last
thing you say to them it's such a
pleasure to see you thanks for coming
over
it's such a fun time tonight I'm gonna
need your left sock here's my left sock
board it's down in the paper do you
wanna see it as you can see here there
are many many left socks from lots of
wonderful people and now I require yours
I there was a time in my life when when
when I spent time in sort of like yeah I
don't know punk rock flophouse tight
places where you would go and like spend
the night cuz you needed a place to
sleep cuz you're on tour and such and
places like that would often have like
you just write on the wall which is kind
of a cool thing but like also you know
not not the way that we imagined
aesthetics being okay these days to just
like take out a sharpie and write on a
on a house isn't how we respect our
living spaces but the very but very cool
in the places where I have done it I I
would much rather just have a guest book
frankly then a wall devoted to signature
yeah that we invented that idea Hank and
then we just kind of we made it smaller
than a wall and more portable lovely I'm
glad that we've made the journey all the
way from everybody who visits this place
has to leave their pee too you know why
not just sign your name in a guestbook
and write a little note ok enough more
than enough really this next question
comes from Chris who writes hey brothers
I was lying in bed thinking about
hamburgers and how does you do bowling
yes
sesame seeds on them not the buns that
Hank eats if you married a hamburger in
the ground could the sesame seeds still
sprout into a sesame plant this was not
really a question designed for someone
with a light Lisp would the burger help
or hurt this process sealed with a Chris
good you know I think probably sesame
seeds have been toasted to the point
where they can are no longer viable
seeds I think that mostly we fairly
toasted sesame seeds though I wasn't I
did a little bit of light research and
was not able to discover whether or not
you could plant a burger bun and and
have a sesame plant grow but it turns
out sesame plants are pretty easy to
grow if you have viable sesame seed hmm
okay yeah they are a desert crop they
don't need a lot of water and 75% of
Mexico's sesame seed crop is purchased
by McDonald's for use globally in fact
not just in the US Wow well and you
can't eat them I can't I cannot eat some
you seeds it's it's a it's too bad and
you're not you're missing out on almost
nothing uh well I'm missing out on all
the things that they put between the
sesame seed buns which right I guess I
is still not great I mean I had a Big
Mac recently because McDonald's has had
an ad campaign and their ad campaign is
like have you had a Big Mac recently and
I was like I haven't and I found myself
like driving fast at McDonald's and I
was like dang that advertising campaign
worked so well because I'm about to have
a big bang I don't know if I've ever had
a Big Mac it's the one with like the
third piece of bread right that is
correct it's like a club sandwich with a
burger with a special sauce which is
just Thousand Island dressing I think
and not like high end Thousand Island
dressing either so I had a Big Mac
usually I would tailor my hamburger
order you know so that I can have the
hamburger I want but this time I was
just thinking I'm gonna go full on and
what the advertisement told me to do
which is just to have a Big Mac yes I
went to the drive-through I just said
can I have a Big Mac please first off I
was astonished by how much it cost the
the calor
two dollar ratio of a Big Mac is really
excellent but the Big Mac itself was a
complete disappointment yeah
Oh God it was very below average I'm
sorry it's gonna be very awkward winning
a few episodes from now McDonald's
sponsors the podcast and we're like have
you had a big mug lately thanks to our
sponsor McDonald's purveyor of the
finest highly processed food available
in America today no I thought the Big
Mac was a complete disappointment I have
to say and I I don't even mind a
disgusting fast-food burger I really
like them but this this one did not do
it for me I like the little ones John
that's why I never get a Big Mac because
I mostly want like a very small
hamburger
oh yeah no my that's my my McDonald's
order he has two cheeseburgers and fries
yeah the double cheese - cheese and
these things like 59 cents it's a bits
how did this happen how did this food
occur for less than a second - Waya
how's that happening are you trying to
make slightly off-topic but are you
trying to make a second away I happen
yeah I think that's I think that's
that's a common phrase we call it a
Sacagawea it's nothing like a muffled
refer to to one dollar as a Sacagawea
you think that's something that anyone
has ever done other than you I think
it's a very common way of saying a
dollar yes Hank people don't even spend
second your ways John the only way to
make change happen is to assume and to
pretend as if you are living in the
world that has already changed that's
very beautiful if only you weren't
applying it Sacagawea and I mean
whatever $1 coins are better than $1
bills I'm onboard Hank I'm calling it a
second away from here on out right I
love III just I love to acquire and
spend sacagawea's that they're worth a
tenth of a Hamilton and a hundredth of a
grant 50th of a Benjamin weighs grant on
the hundred oh no I think Benjamin's on
the hundred the Sacagawea it's worth
four quarters which reminds me John that
this podcast is
brought to you by me being right maybe
right John being wrong it happened
sometime today's podcast is also brought
to you by the United States Mint the
United States Mint still trying to make
second you way as happen minty fresh
this podcast is also brought to you by a
snake with human hands snake with human
hands also a newt and of course today's
podcast is brought to you by John's pet
gopher tortoise Jones that gopher
tortoise very probably fictional and
additionally this podcast is brought to
you by our actual sponsor this week John
the game Rolfe it just came out we did a
Kickstarter for it a while back and it
got funded and we made it and now it is
a game in the real world and it's really
fun it's fun party game you can look it
up you can like type in Hanks channel
Ralph if you want to see me playing it
with some of my friends I'd play it with
John on the podcast here but it does
require us to be able to see each other
and we cannot currently see each other
it is a phenomenally fun game I have to
say it is everything that I want in a
party game and I have no financial
interest in Roth whatsoever so I feel
like I can say this it is funny it is
weird it is much more fun than the rules
make you think it will be and you end up
having a great time with your friends
and I really really dig it so yeah do
check out Rolfe it's great it's so so
surprisingly fun it's rough rol F and
you can find it for sale at dftba.com
alright thanks to our actual sponsor hey
while we're here Hank we also need to
start sharing some of the project for
awesome messages that people bought to
support charities during the project for
awesome this year we really appreciate
all the people who did this and we're
gonna share some of the messages that
they bought on dear Hank and John
beginning with Aaron and Julian in
Melbourne I think Australia our friends
Aaron and Julian and Melbourne would
like to congratulate the Richmond Tigers
who won the AFL Grand Final in 2017 we
are so lucky to be alive
during this momentous age it was their
first grand final win in 37 years whoa
what does the grand final and honestly
is the AFL Australian Football League I
I googled this it is Australian rules
football which I once saw a real-life
game of when I was in Australia and I
have never been more astonished by a
game whose rules I could not follow in
the least if the grand final like the
Superbowl of AFL I believe that the
Richmond Tigers are now the world
champions of Australian rules football
all right after 37 years so
congratulations to them that's
incredibly exciting also Goku would
totally beat Superman in a fight they
would like us to note so we have I mean
there's only one way to find out John
and that's to have whoever owns good
dragon ball acquire whoever owns
Superman and then they can make a movie
Goku vs Superman and it probably won't
be very good well I'll tell you this
given the decreasing number of Hollywood
studios it is only a matter of time
before they are all all intellectual
property is owned by one company so
that's that's an exciting future that we
have to look forward to okay before we
get to the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon which is tremendously exciting
this week and and really worth staying
around for I need to get to one
correction from Daniel who wrote Dear
John and Hank this is dr. Daniel Ray
content consultant for the now complete
crash course computer science series
I've just listened to your most recent
episode and I found your computer
science advice to listeners Sam and
Michael concerning their Wi-Fi security
uniquely and acutely dubious it will do
them no good to change their SSID to an
absolutely remarkable thing and their
password to available for pre-order and
now 9:25 2018 because that test still
won't answer whether their Wi-Fi
interloper is a hacker or merely a
well-meaning but misguided nerdfighter
nor offered them much protection against
either here's what I think you should
have said Sam and Michael it is not
okay for someone to hack or even guess
your Wi-Fi password or user Wi-Fi
without permission nerdfighter
notwithstanding your first step should
be to change your password to a random
string of at least 10 characters
including special characters and
numerals and consider using a password
manager to keep up with hard to remember
passwords if you don't already also be
sure to check your router settings and
turn off your SSID broadcast this will
put your router in stealth mode and
you'll have to manually enter your
router name on all your devices but
otherwise your router literally spends
all day advertising its existence to
everyone that might happen by above all
else
please don't base your personal security
solely on your routers security settings
depending on your particular settings
your Internet traffic encryption is
either profoundly broken probably
breakable or barely serviceable and
likely to be broken at any moment in
this case let your inner paranoid out
make your routers encryption only the
first line of defense you have against
prying digital eyes encrypt everything
as much as possible on every device that
even catches a whiff of your routers
connection so terrifying at all but that
is what an actual computer science
expert thinks that you should do Sam and
Michael and that also contains a lot of
advice for me and I suspect most of us
so there there you go
like I hope I open up my little my
little Wi-Fi thingy and it's just like I
don't even live in a particularly dense
area and there's like tons tons of these
things yeah why are they trying to hack
me there's everybody's around go back
neighbor person well I think we both
know why they're trying to hack you Hank
to get my awesome bath bomb ideas yes
that is why we got that email from The
Associated Press recently about the
state-sponsored actors trying to hack
into our email it was to get your bath
bomb ideas I mean that literally did
happen and I asked him I was like he was
like the Russians tried to hack you and
we found your name and a list of people
that the Russians tried to hack do you
know why and I was like do you know why
Coover I make podcasts well I was also
my response I was like and he would say
he told us how many names were on the
list and I was like that is not nearly
enough names to have naturally arrived
at Hank and John like why what did we do
I don't want to be on this list that's
terrifying please take me off the list
sir can I believe talked to someone at
Russia about taking my name off the list
i I'm just a man in Montana I made a lot
of jokes about Putin in crash course
world history but you have to understand
I thought that they were jokes I didn't
realize that he was actually watching my
every move uh-huh yep we're done making
videos about the Ukraine John it's just
over that's that was a tick I take it
back I I it's funny because I am
genuinely terrified this isn't the first
time this has happened it's happened a
bunch of times and it is really really
scary when it happens and it does affect
the way that people talk like it does
affect people's public discourse when
they know that when they have this like
constant private knowledge that really
sophisticated hackers are attempting
many many times to get access to your
private email which they will then want
to share it's it's a weird feeling and I
don't feel like we are nearly important
enough to be experiencing this but
whatever let's move on all right can I
tell you the news from AFC Wimbledon
sure hey here's the news from AFC
Wimbledon AFC Wimbledon played Bristol
Rovers on Saturday February 17th if they
tied that game they would be in a
position where in order to secure the 52
points that will likely be needed to
stay out of the relegation zone and
therefore stay in the third tier of
English football if they tied that game
they would have needed 1.3 points per
game on average from their remaining
games which would have meant that they
basically have to win every other game
which is much better than they have been
doing yes oh that's that that's
worrisome
and in the 92nd minute of that game it
looked like that's what was gonna go
down it looks like it's going to be a
nil nil draw for the people who don't
know how football works or soccer that
it's a 90 minute game and then right
then there's overage for like like extra
time that might have not gotten played
because and like that those that time is
kind of like subjective and it's
determined by the refs and you don't
know how long it's gonna go so there's a
weird moment at the end of a soccer game
when you don't know when it's gonna end
which is very weird to me it is a little
weird the injury time thing is a little
odd but in this particular game there
were at least three minutes of injury
time which I know because your hero in
mind Joe Piggott scored a goal in the
93rd minute of the game with nearly the
last kick of the game it was an
incredible goal because John Meads and
Harry Forester had to work so hard out
on the wing to keep control of the ball
and they did it and they got a cross
into the middle and Joe Piggott put it
in the back of the net and Wimbledon
went from needing 1.3 points per game
from their remaining games to stay up to
needing 1.13 points for game from their
remaining games to stay up which is much
much better because that's about what
we've averaged this season so really we
just need to keep being about as good as
we've been on average and we should be
able to stay up and if we do stay up we
are going to remember this game against
Bristol Rovers as the critical game
because if it wasn't for that
last-second goal things might have been
very very different indeed Wimbledon now
find themselves all the way up in 18th
place oh wow well bear in mind that you
can only be in 20th and stay up so it's
not that good but yeah 18th place one
point clear of the relegation zone
that's right
one we densely packed there at the
bottom I guess it's a bit dense at the
bottom there's there's quite a lot of
teams not doing great the one team that
that does appear likely to go down at
least at the moment is the franchise
currently plying its trade in Milton
Keynes obviously if the script writers
are writing this it comes down to the
last game of the season with either the
real Dawn's or the fake Don's headed
down to Ligue 2 I really hope that the
script writers aren't writing this and
that Wimbledon just win their next five
games put all of this out of
consideration and we can all go back to
not waking up every morning looking at
extremely complicated graphs of how many
points were needed in each of the last
27 seasons in order to stay in Ligue 1
cool well I'm glad I went when I saw
that note come up you know like I'm on
my little feed and it said Joe Pig it 90
plus 3 I was like are you what meaning
one point scored in the game in the
third minute of overage I texted you
immediately there was probably the first
football related text I've ever received
from Hank it felt like a big step
forward in our relationship by the way
some people have written in to ask how
they can support the two Dons there are
a few ways I just want to go over a
couple real quick before we get to the
news from Mars which is of course
extremely important one way is that you
can become a member of the Dons trust
which only costs about 35 bucks a year
and then you can become a part owner of
the team you can just Google AFC
Wimbledon Don's trust to become a member
and an owner of the team it's pretty
cool you get a card and you get a letter
a birthday card every year signed by the
players or maybe that's only for the
kids I can't remember anyway it's great
being a member of the Dons trust because
you know you get to own the football
team that you support and another way is
you can buy merch you can buy merch at
their store you can also buy merch at
dftba.com where we've got a great AFC
wimbledon nerdfighteria scarf that'll
keep you warm and remind you of your
favorite third tier English soccer team
John and news from Mars we you know
about NASA's James Webb Space Telescope
right oh yeah of course
so the Dempo Space Telescope is designed
to see things that are very far away and
are very faint and in order to do that
it is going to be basically hiding in a
shadow in space so that it isn't being
hid at all
by the Sun and it's bit will be in the
shadow of the earth and it will be there
all the time and so it'll be nice and
cold no interference from the Sun at all
and it'll be able to take these
extremely sensitive measurements of deep
space and things that are very far away
but there's also some guaranteed
observation time going to observe Mars
and this is a little weird because of
course if you want to observe Mars
there's lots of spacecraft right there
at Mars doing it so why would we need
something that's far away from Mars
observing Mars well I'll tell you John
because when you're in orbit around a
planet you can actually only see a
little bit of it at a time so if if I'm
a satellite orbiting Earth or orbiting
Mars I only get to take a picture of
what I'm above right now or what my lens
can see in its field of view whereas the
web we'll be able to observe Mars in
total all at once and it will be able to
do extremely sensitive measurements of
Mars which will allow it to see things
like atmospheric composition how much
water there is coming off the surface
and into the atmosphere how much methane
there is in the atmosphere which is a
big question right now because we're
finding weird trace amounts of methane
and we don't really know where it's
coming from and this will will help with
that but this is a huge kind of problem
for the web it's not really designed to
do this but they want to use it for this
purpose because there's no better tool
up there to do it because it's really
designed to see stuff that's much
farther away like Mars it's basically
too close so they have to do a number of
things so that the light coming from
Mars isn't so bright that it overwhelms
the telescope sensors and and they have
to also because Mars is so close it
actually for the web will be moving
quite quickly so the Webb telescope will
have to track Mars as it moves in you
know relative to its to the telescope's
position which means that it like what
whereas if it's observing a star that
start is staying in the same place
the telescope is moving around the Sun
but the star is staying in the same
place but with Mars both the telescope
is moving around the Sun and Mars is
moving in a different path around the
Sun which creates a lot of necessary
movement for web to track with the
planet and continue these observations
which is really cool that it's possible
at all and that these observations are
going to be able to get done by what
will be the most sensitive telescope
ever created and it will tell us more
about the history of Mars and about
current current day Mars as well now
it's very interesting just a quick
correction if I might okay and correct
me if I'm wrong about this correction
which I think there's at least a 75%
chance of stars do move right it's just
they move relatively slowly via they
move they move very slowly you could
actually see animations of how
constellations will change over the next
you know hundred thousand years yeah
and so like the people who lived like
the humans that lived a hundred thousand
years ago we looked up and saw a
different night sky with different
constellations which is a crazy thing to
think but it is the case but yeah the
stars move relative to each other they
of course rotate around the center of
their galaxy
so yeah stars do move they just move
relatively slowly yeah I just wanted to
say that because I think one of the most
interesting things about the universe is
how we were always looking for the fixed
point you know first we thought it was
the earth and we thought it was the Sun
and it turns out that there maybe aren't
fixed points yes I mean that's what
relativity is thought of all about yeah
yeah I just think that's such an
interesting and kind of beautiful thing
anyway thanks for parting with me today
Hank it's been a pleasure yeah it's been
fun hanging out with you as well John
what if anything did we learn today very
little if we're being honest I mean it
wasn't our best performance I suppose we
learned that the Richmond Tigers when
the AFL Grand Final in 2017 yes we did
and we learned that if you would like to
take
record of the visitors to your home
probably a good physical memento is just
a guest book and not a piece of their
body or secretions yep probably just
stick with a guest book we also learned
that holding grudges over decades is not
recommended and we learned that John is
abandoning optimism it's over it's over
for me and optimism I'm all the way on
pessimism now I'm going hard the other
direction I am a full time pessimist
humans have no future it does seem a
little bit more like your natural state
to be to be totally like sort of
Brotherly Frank with you yeah no I think
what what you're feeling is that I am in
a lot of ways a negative person like I'm
a person who worries a lot about
negative outcomes and negative
consequences and and dries through
worrying about them to prevent them but
I don't think that that means that I've
been a pessimistic person in my life in
fact I think that I've been quite
optimistic and I've benefited from that
optimism but now I'm going to see if I
can benefit more from being hardcore
pessimistic okay we'll see how it goes
thank you for everyone for listening to
us if you would like to listen to our
bad podcast which is available for our
patrons on patreon you can go to
patreon.com/crashcourse in which we and
try and figure out who the other one is
talking about for about 15 minutes and
then we make fun of each other also if
you want to email us you can do so at
Hank and John at gmail.com we welcome
your questions and we love answering
them but we apologize for the fact that
we don't answer the vast majority of
them there are so many good ones this
podcast is edited by Nicholas Jenkins
it's produced by rosianna halse rojas
and sheridan Gibson our head of
community and communications is Victoria
bon giorno the music that you're hearing
and the music at the beginning and the
beginning of this weekend Ryan's is by
the great gunnarolla and as they say in
our
hometown don't forget be awesome
[Music]